what up guys welcome to the just Hurley
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
whiteboard videos before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification Bell the way
you're gonna be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in
let's get started so today I want to
talk about how there is no good option
for men in 2023. now before you get
triggered okay hear me out all right
this is why I say there's no such thing
as a good woman because if you say that
oh just find a good woman it's a
fundamental misunderstanding of female
nature now I don't say this in a happy
way however I observe Trends and I come
to conclusions so let's talk about the
average woman
now we have before gone through the
stats on this show you know the average
woman is obsessed with Instagram so
there's her Instagram there's her
thought bubble she's thinking about
Instagram right the average woman has
been with multiple men let's just all
these guys here the average woman a
third has had an abortion third is an
STD so like this is this is Sally right
here okay now are there exceptions yes
okay I'm not saying there's not
exceptions but we're talking about the
average so let's say a guy wants to be
foreign
this is what the man wants he wants a
family and a bunch of kids so he wants
boom boom boom so there's the kids
there's the family this is what the guy
wants okay now the question is how does
Bob get to this and not get screwed over
by this so I gotta give you guys a
little bit of context here so right now
there's a roughly 50
divorce rate now okay 50 divorce rate
let's ask ourselves what is the
reputation of marriage right now we have
phrases like it's cheaper to keep her
happy wife happy life what does this
indicate this indicates that the
reputation of marriage isn't good and I
can tell you from anecdotal experience I
mean person after person after person
that's afraid of marriage because of
what they saw from their parents so
let's take the remaining 50 of people
married today out of this 50 let's
assume 25 percent
suck because if over half of marriages
were good then marriage wouldn't have
the reputation it has today and the
stats will back this up a bit if you
look at marital satisfaction if you look
at sexlessness and marriage we'd all
agree that a dead bedroom marriage is a
bad marriage right now when we take that
into account we have a 75
failure rate now mind you this is with
the people that have already been
married not the people that are going to
get married in the future so knowing
there's a 70 let's just let's we're
shits and giggles right say that 25
percent
are good right okay and this is let's be
honest guys this is a bit I think I'm
being generous saying half of marriages
are good well let's let's go with that
you know let's solve this Trope so this
is something with a 75 failure rate okay
meaning it is more likely to fail than
to succeed now so let's keep this in
mind so marriage 75 failure rate let's
let's go to the next Trope oh and mind
you these are the people that are
already married I'm 26 right are the
women of my generation and younger do
they have the reputation of being better
than the women of before Oh no so can't
we assume that the quality of wives
today is worse than the last quality of
wives that have a 75 failure rate so
wouldn't that indicate that actually the
failure rate might go even higher in
this next Generation I don't see any
indication that women are getting better
and I don't see any indication that
we're more loyal let's let's go and look
at the root of this problem most women
have never even heard what their role as
a wife is I'll say this from anecdotal
experience and from interviewing
hundreds and hundreds of women the role
of a wife right is supposed to be here's
the man here's the woman
okay you're supposed to be as help me
you're supposed to submit to his
authority right but most women want to
be equal actually most women want to be
above the man and that's why we see in
media all of these celebrities of the
men worshiping the woman if you go up to
a typical couple right and you ask them
a question the woman will talk first you
know it's like if you ask you you go
into a company you go and ask a bunch of
people in the room a question it's
usually the people with the most
Authority speak so there's little ways
you could sort of pick out who had wears
the pants in the relationship another
thing you can kind of pick out is my
wife let me if you have the authority in
the relationship why is your wife
letting you why do you have to ask your
why it's very interesting and then
you'll see this too because these women
will get like enraged when you imply
this so we can assume that maybe the 75
failure let's just say another five
percent fail let's just say this is an
80 failure rate okay now let's just say
you're a young guy and you still you
still want the marriage in the family
but you're going into the world and do
you know what you've seen you've seen
your uncle and your dad and maybe your
brother gets screwed over by marriage so
you look at you're like all happy and
you say I want a family maybe some curly
hair
um yeah there we go this is Bob all
right and he says I want a family but
he's gonna look at the risks and he's
gonna look at the rewards and remember
80 failure rate so one of the risks is
losing half your assets so we have an
entire system that is trying to take
your you know where the women are
actually paid to take your ship now
we're going to talk about ways to
mitigate the risk later but let's just
let's just look at what could what is
the worst thing that could happen to you
another risk is your kids hate you now
I've talked to women and men that hated
their fathers for years based off of
information that their mother told them
talking about their dad and a lot
of these kids that hate their parents
were actually from two parent home
imagine with a divorce which is half of
them right so that's a risk that even if
you have a legacy it's really like the
kid could hate you you get divorced she
has custody you know another risk she
wants to leave and step daddy season
right we heard that in the media step
daddy so now you have no control over
who's influencing your daughter or your
son so not only could this person
influence your kid negatively they also
could abuse your kid and they're the one
of the most likely people to abuse your
child is The Stepfather that comes into
the life or the birth mom that's that's
a conversation we don't want to have
okay so another risk your reputation a
lot of women won't go down without a
fight so they want everybody in the
neighborhood to know what a terrible
abuser you are so not only will they
take your make your kids hate you
and bring in an irresponsible stepdad
they'll also tell your entire community
that you're an abuser and the problem is
in Family Court you actually have no way
to fight this because it's not based on
evidence so your reputation so then on
top of that your job some men go through
all of this their reputation is
destroyed sometimes even their family
hates them yes that is how manipulative
women can be kids hate them assets are
gone their reputation and they either
get so stressed out they lose their job
or they're known as abusers so they get
fired now this is a law
there's a lot of risk and the reward
nowadays is 1.5 kids I mean food maybe
cleaning maybe but probably not so you
know you get 1.5 kids you get some meals
cooked maybe she might clean I mean
do women really clean and cook I mean
Arc this is the reward they'll say you
might get a two kids out of the deal
some food some cleaning you're not going
to get a virgin bride that's pretty much
gone can you think of any other reward
is there anything I'm missing okay
nothing I mean oh yeah I forgot about
that oh yeah sex maybe but a lot of
women it's like they get the ring maybe
a hottie maybe oh oh yeah I forgot so
then on top of the risks is
a sexless marriage so they're afraid oh
no what if I marry her and she stops
sleeping with me another risk is I think
this is the ultimate crime for men I
think there's nothing worse for a man I
mean these are pretty bad guys well one
of the ultimate crime
a fat wife
a fat what like I I mean this is just
embarrassing for a guy or another risk
is you know as we're seeing with the
Logan Paul thing wifing an ex-ho and
getting laughed at the men don't want
that either so Guys these risks and so
the reward is okay you might get two
kids you might get some food you might
get some sex but even these are kind of
iffy there's no guarantee there now the
reward used to be okay but at least I
get to keep the kids and she won't leave
but no no fault divorce came in and said
sis leave for whatever reason you want
sis you don't need to give him kids or
any of this stuff sis so now you know
Bob says Okay I want this right this is
the that he wants this but there's a lot
of risk and now a lot of times what I
hear tradcons say is well the men that
walk away from Marriage aren't the men
you want anyway and from my experience
this is not true now you know a lot of
times it's the men that the women
actually did want and they got this but
they didn't know about all of this they
go in very naive so it's a bit
disingenuous to say oh the solution is
get married and have a family when what
is the reward that they get now as a
chick yet guys I I love marriage I think
marriage is great but the way we do
marriage today is actually pretty bad
and I understand why the men are walking
away okay so let's go to the next step
which is Solutions what what is a guy to
do so again he wants this he wants this
he knows they're an 80 failure rate of
this so how does he get there okay you
know men are funny men are funny it's
like if you make a game the men will
just figure out a way to play it they'll
come up with so many solutions it's so
funny okay number one now I want I want
to give you guys some context so women
men don't reach their Peak to like 35.
okay and I've always heard from the guys
the dating kind of changes for the men
in their late 20s early 30s that's when
the women are like hey I want you now
the young women obviously you know as we
talked about 25 year old women are
hotter than 35 year old women the
hottest chicks are between the ages of
18 to let's say 25. maybe we'll up it to
28 but like let's just say that's the
most desirable now not to say that there
aren't hotties over that age but we're
talking in general okay please don't
freak out all the wives out there so the
man knows I can get the youngest hottest
chick when I'm 35 let's say roughly 30
to 40. the men can get the best chick
because now the 20 year olds are dating
the older guys so when they're young the
women don't want them so they think huh
all right 35 years old and they think
how can I mitigate the risk How can I
make it I still want this but I need to
make the risk lower so they think okay
maybe I'll date a woman for three years
which is the average time people now
date before getting married so they say
huh maybe if I date her for three years
it's less risky and maybe we could do
that so two a prenup okay so what
they'll do is they'll say hey we're
gonna get a prenup before we get married
now if you're gonna date for three years
obviously in 2023 they're not really
gonna wait till marriage for three years
all right let's just guys you know we're
gonna have an adult conversation here if
you want to date a girl for three years
you know you got to figure out what
birth control option because with all
that risk we we listed earlier we know
that you don't really want to take any
chances so what you could do is trust
she's on birth control now men how does
that work out anyone anyone let me know
in the comments how does that how does
the trusting her tend to work I mean I
get some feedback not always the best
all right condoms right which could
break but I mean some guys will do that
but they don't they a lot of guys don't
want to wait that long I hate to say it
guys vasectomy please don't freak out
let's just have the conversation
abstinence now or I guess sorry the the
pull out whatever
so these are the these are the options
for birth control so these are these are
ways to mitigate risk this is date for
three years a prenup okay then go get a
church woman this is what I hear a lot
just go to the church Church guys just
go go to church and find a church woman
however then the men go to church and
they they find worse women than in the
general public now don't shoot the
messenger okay
um so they go to church and find a bunch
of single mothers and ex-ho and then
they're like oh I thought I was in
church now this isn't all churches this
isn't every Church woman
um but you know the problem is there's a
lot of men that come to me and say
Church made their wife worse because of
single women Ministries that just tell
them what they want to hear and
pandering Pastor okay but you know I'm
just going through the options all right
so get a church woman thing I hear I
hear men do passport Bros they're tired
of the old fat in America so they
say I am going to go to a different
country but the problem with the
passport Bros is a couple things when
they bring back the women from the other
countries to America I I get I get some
feedback that the same thing happens and
the woman go crazy or the UK the other
thing is that you know a lot of these
countries also have declining birth rate
which indicates that the country is more
modern and what I hear from a lot of the
more traditional countries is their
women are getting ruined to because of
social media because women we're such a
group think we're so hive-minded we hear
whatever's on the TV and social media we
want to do what's cool and right now
it's really cool to be a fat I
mean body positivity sexual Liberation
oh that's like trendy and cool and women
just I don't know what's I don't know
what it is about us okay now the
passport Bros okay
some guys you know now I know this I got
in a lot of trouble for this one some
guys choose to get a vasectomy until
they're 35 and they can date a girl for
a couple years and pick one and they
think huh a vasectomy is actually less
risky than marriage yes guys let's have
that conversation most vasectomies are
reversible I'm not saying to do it I'm
not saying it's the best option but when
marriage has an 80 failure rate
I mean is this more risky or less so
some guys go that route okay some guys
put all their Assets in their parents
name as we see as we saw that famous
divorce where that woman tried to get
all his assets and found out he had none
some guys do a non-government marriage
but this still does not mitigate the
risks that come with kids some guys this
is rare but some guys hire a surrogate
some guys literally pay a woman to carry
their child so they know that that is
their child some guys will never get
married and just have a girlfriend
forever that's it and then pray to God
that she doesn't ruin them you know I've
even heard examples of guys somehow
wiggling around the laws and making
their girlfriend pay all of the rent so
she has no right to their stuff
okay now mind you I I've heard a lot of
a lot of pushback well a family is
totally worth the risk it's totally
worth all of your that's just stuff
you can make it back well guys well I
hate to break it to you I'm just gonna
be honest Pearl's just an honest person
when your kids hate you is it worth it
to a guy because men really care about
Legacy and a lot of guys just they want
this but they don't want to go through
all of this to get this it's just not
like they just they look at the pros
they look at the cons and they say this
is a lot of work just to maybe get a kid
in half so now this leads some men to
mgtow now what is mgtow these are the
men that look at this and they say oh no
as much as I want this I'm not doing all
of this to get this an 80 failure rate
now guys let's go into their point of
view would you ever sign a contract with
an 80 failure rate ever if I said hey
you take this pill 20 chance you'll live
forever ever eighty percent chance you
will die or eighty percent chance you
will lose everything that you care about
would you take that pill yeah it's so
weird we shame men for for going the
mgtow route so a lot of people say I'm a
Doomer I'm not a Doomer I just say enjoy
enjoy the decline you know what I mean
so okay all right so now what is mgtow
mgtow is all the men that say okay
they're all fat anyway I'm tired
of this now there is no way for a man to
interact with a woman and not have a
concept now okay all right so these this
could be love this could be amazing
however feminism has basically ruined
all right so what if a guy looks at this
and says so he says you know what I'm
never getting married but I still want
to interact with women so the first type
of mgtow is men that go their own way
but just from marriage so they'll still
have a nice girlfriend here but they're
they're not gonna ever legally get
married okay but the problem with that
is this woman can can still take she can
still take kids there are some states
that have common law marriage where if
you live together long enough you're
legally married so you know she could
still take money ruin reputation so
there's some guys that look at that and
say huh I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
back off of that one I'm good but you
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna just
have sex casually but that woman could
still me to him an example right now is
Russell Brandt where he had sex casually
for years he's married now but let's
just say he never got married those
women could still ruin career now there
are men that find ways about around this
where they will record their entire
house or make sure they get text or
video consent before everything
um however there's more and more laws
prohibiting that behavior saying that
you can't record a woman without her
knowing whatever wait I okay under
understandably but it's like damned if
you do damned if you don't hear so some
guys say I'm just gonna have sex
casually no kid okay marriage sex
casually and some guys just say
they say it and they say it
I'm gonna go get an AI girlfriend watch
porn forever or just never deal with any
of this because this is too much
and this is why I would implore the
politicians watching this to change some
of the laws around marriage family and
relationship because the way it is now
traditional men are punished and a lot
of people give really bad advice around
this so what I see right now is a
generation of men that have been misled
especially I I come from the
conservative background so you know
these guys were told hey you're gonna
put Bob here back curly hair smiley face
just find a good woman and marry young
and these guys say okay let me go do it
and they find Susie and Susie's awesome
and she's great but then what they don't
know is after marriage Susie becomes a
fat whale now there's Susie and they're
like hey hey I thought I thought I
thought we had a good thing I thought we
had a good thing going no now she's a
bitter fat will and then she takes the
kids and ruins his life so now he's sad
because he didn't know that when he got
married that he was signing up for a
system that pays women to leave okay and
the bad advice they give is just find a
good woman this is a fundamental
misunderstanding of female nature this
is absolutely a fundamental
misunderstanding people that say just
find a good woman do not understand the
nature of women women we just basically
have this like group thing I don't know
what it is about us don't know why and I
know everyone's gonna come at me Pearl
Pearl Pearl aren't you a good woman I'm
still a woman you know what I mean like
so okay women there's there's Sally are
very influenced by the media here's
Instagram the culture so other women so
women are very we're very influenced
like women are just for whatever reason
we're just like very influenced being so
we're influenced by the media and the
culture and even a good woman over the
course of 50 years and the media telling
her she's better on her own her friends
in the culture saying she's better on
her own and now there's a fat Payday for
going go leaving and ruining everything
so even a good woman on her worst day is
absolutely capable there's no woman that
is not capable of doing something like
this every chick has it in them I'm not
saying every woman will but any woman
can and knowing this information it's
very naive to just find a good woman and
assume that she's going to do the right
thing because the truth of the matter is
I've I've you know I I'm doing a divorce
documentary guys and I've interviewed
men that had traditional women and they
got into the wrong friend group they
started watching the wrong content or
they got into the wrong legal system or
um or they got the wrong lawyer and they
just ruined that guy's life now this is
why I would argue that marrying young is
equally as risky as getting a vasectomy
now I'm not pleased no I know what
they're gonna do they're gonna be like
Pearl's pushing it I'm not pushing it
what I am trying to say is pushing young
men into marriage without them knowing
what they're up again is very naive and
it's bad advice and I've met so many men
on the brink of suicide that absolutely
would have been better off going mgtow
so you know every guy has to decide for
himself what he wants to do some men
it's worth the risk some man it's not
but every guy's got to decide for
himself so you know this is this is
what's going on in the dating market
today politicians we need to change
these laws really if we want to see the
family unit come back together like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time
[Music]
foreign